los antiguos políticos el ex prefecto de
mama y el actual presidente en nana
akufo addo en 2012 john mama ganó las
elecciones a una votación cerrada pero
disputada cuatro años después nana
akufo-addo ganó a estas elecciones
permiten estar un poco con una pendencia
entre los dos hombres el desempleo la
educación y la salud son las principales
de los principales temas en juego en
estas elecciones y son temas que todos
los candidatos plantearon durante su
campaña electoral campaña que además fue
restringida por la epidemia del corolla
virus
ghana es un ejemplo de democracia en la
región a diferencia de muchos de sus
vecinos el país ha disfrutado de un
sistema político estable y eficiente
desde hace 25 años pero a medida que
avanzan las elecciones las naciones son
cada vez más mayores este año muchos
observadores temen que la competencia
electoral puede llegar a la violencia
semana pasada el gobierno ha anunciado
la presencia del ejército
en la región del volta que es
considerado como un punto sensible